chief hopper do you copy we repeat chief
hopper do you copy
listen we know the ending tells us one
thing but our hearts tell us another and
we're more than a little convinced that
you're locked up abroad but listen we
don't want to wait another year or so to
find out the truth so stop this radio
silence and give us the deets already
chief hopper do you copy or not this may
take a while if you didn't shed a single
tear during the stranger things season 3
finale you belong in the upside down the
season finale is loaded with clues of
what's to come
keep watching to find out why some fans
are convinced that hopper is kicking it
in Russia from villain to hero Billy's
always been reckless and dangerous
making him the perfect villain after a
run-in with the mind flayer Billy
totally lost his marbles stay away from
me carrot
[Music]
he kidnapped and sacrificed anyone he
could get his hands on bring them to the
mind flayers tribute Billy's main goal
was to capture 11 and bring her to his
leader with her out of the way the mind
flayer would prevail or so we thought
but during the battle at Star Court mall
Billy had a change of heart and
sacrificed himself for 11 his demise was
brutal and terrifying but hey he died a
hero
for anyone wondering if Billy managed to
survive his injuries tantras no Billy
Hargrove is definitely a goner but
fortunately his sister max will be able
to remember him as a hero instead of a
monster infested villain
goodbye buyers Joy's buyers hasn't had
an easy run her son went missing
everyone thought she was crazy and then
her loyal and sweet boyfriend Bob kicked
the bucket in the most terrible way
possible so it makes total sense that
she would choose to move out of Hawkins
Indiana hoppers alleged deaths cemented
Joyce's decision to leave Hawkins and
she made it a point to take 11 with her
Joyce Jonathan will and L are packing up
and moving on but they're leaving a lot
of emotional baggage behind we don't
exactly know where the buyers are moving
to but they did promise to visit over
the holidays so they can't have gone too
far perhaps season four will take place
during Thanksgiving or Christmas holiday
Elevens powers 11 has never needed help
getting something from the top shelf
before but now it seems as though her
powers are taking a sabbatical it's not
the first time 11th powers have dwindled
after matching the mountain battle so
much like max many fans are confident
that Elle's powers will come back with a
vengeance
sadly spying on Mike and her friends
won't be possible so they'll have to
take advantage of Dustin's trusted radio
until Elle's mental battery recharges
the mind flayer was convinced that 11
was the only one who could stop him but
boy was he wrong thanks to Joyce and
hopper sacrifice the gate to the upside
down was closed severing the mine player
from his body Nancy and Jonathan Nancy
Drew and her trusted partner have been
through a lot they've shared trauma
amongst many other things and now
they're sharing a heartfelt goodbye well
we have no idea what Jonathan will do
when he gets to his new destination
we're fairly certain that Nancy won't be
getting awful men their coffees and
breakfast sandwiches any longer
Nancy definitely wrote about what happ
at the star Court mall and probably used
it as leverage to get a reporting job
who knows he might even become the
investigative reporter for the Hawkins
Post apparently their old one was
reported missing how unfortunate is the
mind flayers still alive
Billy Hargrove may be dead but it would
appear the mind flayer is still very
much alive Joyce may have separated the
mind flayer from his physical body when
she closed the gate to the upside down
but that wasn't enough to destroy the
monster once and for all he's still
alive in the upside down and is surely
plotting his next big attack the gate
may be closed but the upside down is
still a very real thing it's only a
matter of time before a military force
attempts to breach the upside down once
again due to the Russians involvement
many fans believe there to be a second
gate somewhere in Russia which would
explain why a demo dog was spotted
during the season 3 finale bonus scene
Cline - swine Mayor Larry Klein will go
down and Hawkins in the end of history
as the worst mayor of all time we see
mayor Klein being carried away by police
officers at the end of season 3 so it's
safe to say that someone new will come
into power very soon we just hope that
this new mayor is gonna have his
people's best interests at heart with
hopper gone we can also expect a new
Chief of Police so this means we might
see a whole new governing force take
place in season for his hopper still
alive hopper sacrificed himself so that
his loved ones could live the blast
completely annihilated him leaving no
body behind but we just can't accept his
death especially after hearing his
heartfelt letter 211 the bonus scene
feeds into the conspiracy surrounding
hoppers death we see a Russian military
base lined with cells when a soldier
goes to open a cell his superior says no
not the American they select a Russian
prisoner instead and feed him to a demo
dog fans are convinced that his
mysterious American is none other than
chief hopper himself but how on earth
did he get there
do you guys think hopper is still alive
if so how do you reckon he wound up in
Russia sound off in the comments give
this video a big thumbs up if you're
excited for stranger things season 4 and
be sure to subscribe to the things for
the latest strange of things news thanks
for watching see you next time
[Music]